♪♪
AJAK
Five years ago, Thanos erased
half of the population
of the universe.
But the people of this planet
brought everyone back
with the snap of a finger.
The sudden return
of the population...
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin.
♪♪
[Waves crashing]
IKARIS
How long do we have?
AJAK
Seven days.
♪♪
SERSI
We're Eternals.
We came here 7,000 years ago...
to protect humans
from the Deviants.
[Roar]
DANE WHITMAN
Why didn't you guys help fight Thanos?
Or any war? Or all the other
terrible things throughout history?
♪♪
SERSI
We were instructed not to interfere
in any human conflicts
unless Deviants were involved.
DANE WHITMAN
By who?
♪♪
IKARIS
We need to find the others.
♪♪
SERSI
I haven't seen some of them for centuries.
KINGO
Hi.
THENA
Hello.
SPRITE
If this is what the end of
the world looks like...
at least we have
front-row seats.
PHASTOS
You know what's never saved the planet?
Your sarcasm.
♪♪
THENA
We have loved these people
since the day we arrived.
When you love something...
you protect it.
♪♪
KRO
You can't protect...
any of them.
♪♪
[Roar]
[Grunt]
♪♪
IKARIS
I bet you've built the perfect safe house.
And what's this even made of?
Vibranium?
PHASTOS
Don't!
[Objects clattering]
Fall collection.
IKEA.